Have you ever made this mistake writing
copy? Check this out. A lot of copy that
I see nowadays has vague statements like
this. Many clients or my car or more
revenue or fast and really it needs to
be hyper-specific which increases the
believability of what you're saying.
When you say many clients, say 103
clients, okay? Don't say my car, say my
'69 red Camaro, okay? Don't say more
revenue, say $15,459
in revenue, okay? Be really specific
with it. Don't say fast, say in 60
seconds, okay? You want to be as
specific as possible in everything that
you write because specificity increases
believability and the more somebody
believes your copy, the more they buy
from your copy.